[Music]
hello everyone thanks a lot for coming
today we are here to discuss how you can
develop deploy and debug applications
using Google cloud platform developer
tools
I'm Nikhil called I'm the product
marketing manager for developer tools at
Google cloud and with me I have Russell
I'm Russell Wolff and I'm the product
manager for cloud source repositories so
as you might have seen in the previous
slide the way we structured this
presentation is essentially into three
parts in the first and the foremost part
we specifically wanted to talk about
developing applications in the second
part we wanted to showcase how you can
deploy those applications and in the
third part we specifically wanted to
deep dive into debugging an app in the
first part when we talk about developing
an application we wanted to deep dive
into how you can store your source code
on Google cloud platform the different
integrations which are available to make
developers productive as a part of
storing that source code and finally the
different features which are available
to build security and in the second part
which is essentially targeted at
deploying we wanted to showcase how you
could use cloud source repositories
specifically to build test and deploy an
app and finally in the third phase of
the presentation we wanted to showcase
how you can use cloud source
repositories along with the different
integrations with stack driver for
debugging and applications the one thing
which you would see across these three
different phases is we are leveraging
cloud source repositories along with the
different integrations it provides so
just to level set and ensure everyone in
the audience
understand what cloud sauce repositories
is we go to the next slide
cloud source repositories is a generally
available service on GCP that allows you
to host private git repositories because
those repositories are hosted on GC P it
makes it really easy to integrate with
other GCP services such as stackdriver
debugger cloud build and cloud pub/sub
there are three areas where cloud source
repositories really excels first is with
its high scalability Google has invested
in a highly scalable get infrastructure
for many years to support the needs of
two of the largest git projects that
exists chromium and Android cloud source
repositories uses that same highly
scalable get infrastructure which means
that you can host large files large
folders large repositories and do it all
for many users with a very low latency
next cloud source repositories has high
reliability because all repositories are
hosted in multiple data centers across
different regions in theory even if half
the world's network was disconnected
all repositories would still be able to
be served we even isolate data centers
and perform periodic disaster recovery
tests just to be sure your source code
is safe and finally to help meet your
organization's compliance needs cloud
source repositories doesn't just
integrate with Identity and Access
Management meaning that you get to use
the same identity you use for the rest
of your organization and use a
consistent permission model used with
the rest of your cloud resources it also
features audit logging which means that
if something were to go wrong such as
code exfiltration you can be sure that
you can do an investigation and figure
out what happened who did it and when it
happened cloud source repositories also
does daily globally redundant backups
which means that if some disaster were
to occur your source code is safe and
finally with automatic encryption in
transit with per repository encryption
keys your IP is protected so remember
the three pieces of the presentation
develop deploy and debug so let's start
with the first phase of how cloud source
repositories can actually help you
develop applications there are two ways
to connect your source code to GCP first
you can do it by mirroring your code
from an external get provider such as
github or bitbucket you only need to set
up that mirror once and all of your
source code is copied over after that
any time you make a new commit to github
or bitbucket that commit is then copied
over to cloud source repositories as
well now you may be asking the question
what benefits do I get from copying my
source code over to GCP well first you
can take advantage of code search we'll
dive into that a bit later but I can
just tell you that Googlers rely on it
every day and I bet you'll find it great
too second you can take advantage of a
bunch of other integrations that cloud
source repositories has with other GCP
services for example five pub/sub cloud
build and stack driver debugger and
we'll also demo all of those later
alternatively you can choose the host
your source code directly on Google
cloud platform in class or repositories
and have your entire development team
collaborate there Thanks we're also
excited to announce an upcoming
integration with git lab which means
that you'll be able to host your
repositories on get lab and mirror all
that source code in the cloud source
repositories to take advantage of all of
those integrations this will be
available in the next month the other
goal of us providing cloud source
repositories is making developers more
productive and traditionally what we see
is developers spend a lot of time trying
to find answers each and every day
answers to questions like
how a function should be called what
does the class look like where does the
class get instantiated why is something
failing or who changed that code
resulting into the codebase failing and
answers to those questions can be easily
found through code search functionality
of cloud sauce repositories code search
allows you to search across your entire
repository with a single query this is
especially useful when you don't have
all of your organization's repositories
cloned down from the server to your
local machine or all of your local repos
aren't up to date with the server
indexing is super fast so even if you're
in a large organization with commits
constantly coming in yours always
searching against up-to-date code in
fact cloud source repositories uses the
same document indexing and retrieval
mechanisms used by Google search which
means that it can handle your searches
quickly and across very large purposes
of code there are three areas where code
search for cloud source repositories
really excels first with support for
regular expression search that means you
can craft queries to answer even the
most complex of questions
second by having a syntax aware index
that means that you're not just
searching for text you can also search
for specific entity types such as a
class or a function and finally with
result suggestions as you type you can
get answers to the questions you're
looking for right away without having to
wade through any search result pages
cloud service repositories also helps
you keep your code secure it's generally
not a good idea to check service account
credentials or security keys into
version control system however sometimes
you may accidentally do that and that's
where cloud source repositories is there
to help with the push block feature
enabled if you try to push a commit to
the server that contains a GCP service
account credential or a security key
that push will be blocked and you'll be
given information telling you what file
was in violation and why it was blocked
if you're committed was just fine it
makes it to the server let's go ahead
and take a look at a demo for this all
we're first gonna start by showing how
you sync a repository from github then
we'll take a look at the source browser
and cloud source repositories and look
at the contents of that repository
after that we'll do a global code search
and finally we'll take a look and see
how push-block works in action this is
the home page of cloud source
repositories here you can see your
favorites and your recently viewed and
these will contain repositories branches
folders and files it helps you quickly
jump back into the context of whatever
you you were last working on we can go
up to the top right and select add
repository to add a new repository and
here we can choose between connecting an
external repository or creating a new
repository we're going to choose to
connect an external repository we're
gonna add it to this cloud project I
created specifically for next and we'll
choose the github provider I'm gonna
authenticate GCP to connect to github
and I've already signed in with my
github account on this computer so I'm
already in here and I'm going to choose
to connect this cloud debugger Python
repository that I have access to on
github I just click connect selected
repository and now cloud source
repositories is setting up a web hook on
that github repository
that way whenever changes happen to that
repo we can then mirror the changes back
over and it's also doing a one-time full
clone of that repository including all
the branches and tags and everything
else it looks like like that repo has
been cloned over so let's take a look
here we can see the layout of the
repository in this branch picker at the
top we can see that it's copied over all
the branches tags and commits we can
also see the readme file for the
repository rendered here and click in
the change history to see the history of
all of the commits that have happened in
this repository as we navigate through
the source browser now I've getting
through folders and even down to files
we can see that the change history
updates for that scope once you're
looking at a file you can click blame to
see which user was responsible for the
changes on each line of code and see the
associated commits and message that goes
along with it you can also go to change
history and select a diff between any
two versions of a file and you can click
on a commit ID to view all of the
changes that took place in that commit
finally you can compare those commits to
other commits in your repository
and see the difference of all the
commits that happened in between as well
as all the changes to the files let's go
ahead and take a look at the code search
functionality now I'm going to change
from searching in this repository to
search them across everything I have
access to and as you can see as I type
individual characters I'm getting these
results suggestions as I type and
they're showing that it's finding
variables functions structs and more I
can go ahead and click on one of these
suggestions and I'm taken directly to
the line of code where that function
exists I can also go to the search box
and just submit this query and view all
of the results across all of the
repositories I have access to
you can go in and preview all the
matches in the file to see if it's what
you're looking for and continue
iterating through these different
previews until you find the exact match
that you were trying to get to this
really helps your developers be
productive and sold those tasks that
Nick Hill was talking about earlier
quickly now let's take a look at how
push-block works I'm going to switch
over to cloud shell cloud shell is
another GCP service that allows you to
use a command line to manage all of your
DCP resources as well as a code editor
and all of this is hosted in a VM just
for you so you can access it from the
browser anytime you want so here I'm
inside of this cloud functions
repository and earlier today I was
actually testing out deploying my cloud
function from a third-party service to
build the nice integration and because I
was doing that I downloaded some GCP
service account credentials to my
machine those are contained in this key
JSON file now later in the day I may go
and make an innocuous change such as
fixing this typo from this repository to
this repository and I'll track it with
get make a quick commit saying fixing
typos and push it to the server
now you see I made a mistake there I was
going quick I just did a git add dot
that added everything in the repository
that wasn't being tracked to be tracked
and here we can see that my push was
rejected push block has said that the
push has been rejected because we detect
that it contains a private key please
check the following commands and confirm
it's intentional I can go ahead and
execute this get show command and it
will show the contents of the private
key which I'm not going to do on stage
and if I detect there was actually
something in there that wasn't a private
key and this was a false detection I can
go ahead and just run git push and
override to say I don't want to keep
track
and with that we've seen how push-block
in cloud source repositories can help
you from making those critical mistakes
that can really put your organization's
security at risk and with that let's go
ahead and switch back to the slides and
Nicola can talk to us about the next
part of our presentation which is
deploying so that that we finished the
first part of the presentation which was
essentially developing an app when it
comes to deploying on an app
many of us are deploying to different
environments these could be VMs these
could be containers these could be
service environments or these could be
mobile platforms irrespective of whether
you're using Google compute engine VMs
google kubernetes engine for deploying
containers service frameworks such as
app engine or functions or mobile
platforms like firebase cloud source
repositories integration with cloud
built can come in really handy here
cloud build is Google's continuous
integration continuous delivery platform
and cloud source repositories integrates
with it in fact as you would see within
the demo the good part about the
integration is that there are no CI
servers to set up manage or maintain as
you would see within few clicks you will
be able to achieve automation from
source to production and the good thing
is you can deploy your app to different
environments in fact if you're someone
who likes to manage their build
configuration as code you can use cloud
builder chiamo specifically for
specifying build steps you can specify
the steps you want to perform as a part
of build you can specify the steps you
want to perform as a part of test and
you can specify the steps you want to
perform as a part of deploy as well
the workflow looks something like this
as a developer I write the code and I
check it in cloud source repositories
from there on cloud will take so long
and cloud poll takes over proudly
because we have set up a trigger to
notify cloud build that a code with a
change has been checked in next as cloud
build takes over cloud build can build
both docker artifacts as well as non non
container specific artifacts example of
these could be Gradle maven go basil etc
etc once the artifacts have been created
cloud build can run different types of
tests whether these are unit tests or
integration tests if you are working
with containers specifically in the
artifact management space which is the
fourth point over there
cloud both can help you scan those
artifacts for vulnerabilities as well
we'll talk more about it in the later
parts of the presentation and finally if
something looks if everything looks
great you can deploy that app to
different environments in the deploy in
the deployment phase however when you
are working in a continuous integration
and continuous delivery environment you
need notifications as a part of that
process you might want notifications
during the start as well as the end and
that's where the notification piece
comes in handy
both outsource repositories and Cloud
bill to offer integrations with cloud
pub/sub that means that when a new
committees checked into your repository
a new bill that's kicked off or a build
completes you can generate a pub/sub
event to a pub subtopic you can then
have a cloud function configured to
monitor that pub subtopic watching out
for these new events coming in and when
a new event comes in and a cloud
function triggers you can have it invoke
a third party service such as slack
email or any other that you want to work
with
before we go on to look at a demo with
us all I'm gonna asking to kill to go
ahead and walk us through the workflow
of what we'll be doing in the demo show
so we have a set up a really simple demo
to demonstrate a continuous integration
and continuous delivery pipeline that's
the first phase of the demo and the
second phase of the demo is essentially
targeted at getting a notification to
slack let's break down these two phases
and go into more detail one by one
both of these two phases essentially
start at the same place which is
developer writing a code and checking it
in into cloud sauce repositories in the
first phase what happens is as deliverer
writes a code and checks it and into
cloud source repositories a build gets
triggered because cloud bill gets a
notification through the build ticket
which we have said once the build gets
triggered cloud one essentially deploys
the app to the test version of App
Engine and runs end to end tests if the
tests pass cloud build then deploys the
app to the production version of App
Engine that completes the first phase of
the continuous integration and
continuous delivery process in the
second stage what we are doing is we are
sending a notification to slag the steps
look something like this starts again
with developer checking in the code
cloud sauce repositories publishes at
event two clouds pops up cloud function
then subscribers subscribes to the pub
sub event and since its subscribing to
the pub sub event it posts the message
which is received in the event to the
slag let's see both of these demos in
action what switch over to the demo
here we can see an application already
deployed to production it's a very
simple app basically it's a guestbook
you can write a message in this box here
such as welcome to next 2019 sign it in
the guestbook and it's posted there
along with the user who wrote it you can
switch over to other guest books as well
and they'll have a distinct set of
messages too and you can log in and log
out of this application now the title
app engine guestbook maybe isn't the
most suitable one so let's go ahead and
change it to next 2019 guestbook just
something easy for us to do here and
we'll change it first by going the cloud
source repositories and I have no idea
actually where this code is declared
it's a simple code change so I can do it
so I'm going to search for App Engine
guestbook and it found the results in
one of these repos and I see it's here
so I can just click Edit code and this
is now going to launch me an instance of
cloud shell it's going to make sure that
this repository is mirrored into this VM
and I'll have this complete workspace in
the cloud here I already have it
mirrored over actually so it's just
asking you to change directory and I'm
at that line of code so I'm gonna change
it from App Engine to next 2019 we'll
add this to get we'll get status and
make sure I'm not checking in any
security keys or anything like that
get commit change in title and then
finally I'll push it to the server
now as this commit gets pushed in the
server just like Nikhil mentioned we're
kicking off a build so let's switch over
to cloud build now and we can refresh
and see that a new build has been
invoked clicking into there we can see
that as three distinct build steps we'll
dig into those into detail in one minute
here you can also see that we have
real-time logs that are being produced
from this build so we can see what's
going on let's go ahead and take a look
at this build trigger that we talked
about
so when toad mated cloud source
repositories it kicked off this build
and told it what to do first
we noticed that there's a trigger type
the trigger type allows you to specify
it when you want this trigger to
activate you have the options between a
branch or a tag and here I've chosen
branch and I can choose a regex that I
want to match for when I want that bill
to be invoked in this case I'm doing a
dot star because I only have one branch
and I just want to trigger off that but
I could also specify an exact branch
name or regex for set of branches I want
to kickoff builds for I can also choose
to filter those builds by changed files
and so here I could use a regex to say I
only want to trigger builds if there are
changes in my source folder or I don't
want to trigger builds if it's just a
change to a config file or a markdown
file once you've decided when you're
going to invoke a build you then get to
decide what you want to do when a bill
is invoked you do that inside of build
configuration by choosing between using
a docker file or a cloud build
configuration file in this case we've
used a cloud build configuration file
pod Yambol let's take a look at this
cloud die animal we can jump back to
cloud source repositories I could search
for it but it's right here and so here
we can see the first step that's
declared in the cloud die animal
this step says we're going to deploy the
current code to a test version on App
Engine without promoting it
I'm just declaring to use this existing
image stored in container registry for
g-cloud I'm saying to form the app
deploy commands and specifying the
optimal for App Engine and an indexed ID
animal for the backing data store and
then I'm specifying these two parameters
version tests so I'm naming that version
and I'm saying not to promote it to
production after that if and only if
that step completes I proceed to the
next step which runs and then tests
against the test version on App Engine
so here I'm just using another image
that's already stored on container
registry which is nubu to image i'm
opening in to bash installing some form
requisites and then executing this run
tests dot bash script here we can see
i'm just declaring the URL for my test
environment on App Engine and I'm
executing the end end tests if for those
tests all succeed I proceed to the next
step which deploys the current code to a
new version on App Engine
that's promoted to serve production
again I just use that G cloud image and
call that same app deploy but this time
I'm not naming it to a test version and
I am letting it promote to production
that's really all there is for setting
up this automated test environment
running my own den tests as well as
promoting the production if those
succeed I recognize many of you might
not use App Engine there are many other
deployment runtimes if you were to
deploy to kubernetes there's cloud build
steps for that if you want to deploy to
cloud functions it's as simple as
specifying your function name and
finally there's even steps if you're
trying to go to mobile and you want to
deploy to firebase now that we've seen
how the cloud build the animals does
that final part of showing what we
should build let's return to the build
and see what's happened
here we can go back to build history and
it looks like the build succeeded we can
see that that first step of deploying to
App Engine in this test environment and
not promoting it took 17 seconds
spinning up that whoo boon to image
installing a bunch of these
prerequisites and then running our end
end integration tests took another 54
seconds but they did pass so that's good
and finally deploying to production and
promoting took another 30 seconds let's
go ahead and check out our application
on production we can refresh this page
and we see that it's now updated to next
2019 guestbook now that we've seen how
that CI CD automated workflow works
let's take a look at that other part of
the demo that Nikhil talked about which
is posting the messages to slack
automatically to inform your team so
here I have a cloud function already
created called CSR to slack it's
watching this pup subtopic I've called
CSR and I've told told cloud source
repositories to post pub/sub events to
that csr topic whenever something
happens like a new commit coming in I'm
then pulling source code for this cloud
function from a different cloud source
repository and executing this message
slack function here we can again go to
cloud source repositories and take a
look at what that looks like
finds it right away from me and we can
see that in this function I'm going to
be messaging the next 2019 channel
saying that users email just push a new
commit to this repository so let's go
over to slack and we can see that it
indeed did post that message to that
channel whether you're trying to
interact with slack or any other third
party service integrations with cloud
pub/sub and cloud functions and make it
really easy now that we've looked at
this demo I'm gonna let Nikhil tell us a
little bit more about some of the
deployed technologies that we have that
are specific to containers so let's go
ahead and switch back to the slides now
so so far what we Russell's showed in
the presentation was really catered
towards App Engine but many of you in
the audience might be using containers
on a day-to-day basis to deploy
applications if you're working with
containers as a part of cloud build we
have something called as vulnerability
scanning one remedy scanning allows you
to identify security vulnerabilities
early on in the software development
process package vulnerabilities for
ubuntu debian are identified right as
soon as the containers are built it also
provides you detailed insight by
providing details such as the security
the severity level of the vulnerability
with what is a CBS s score and whether a
fix is available in fact if you want to
take this process to the next level and
further automate your tool chain you can
use one durability scanning with binary
authorization which will be going G s
own binary authorization essentially
lets you define policies based upon your
organization needs for instance as an
organization you can decide and define
that that we get to deploy only those
containers which are actually tested
what this means is if some developer
actually ends up deploying a container
which was not tested as a part of CI CD
toolchain that container will not get
deployed the image above here is
essentially doing something else however
what we are doing over here is developer
checks according to cloud sauce
repository cloud build creates a build
the container gets scanned by one
already scanning and then essentially
binary authorization checks for a
signature on the image from one Liberty
sense from a Liberty scanning if a
signature is found the container is
deployed to google kubernetes engine and
if a signature is not found audit log is
provided on why
specific steps were not performed with
that we have essentially completed two
thirds of the presentation we
specifically looked at developing an app
we specifically also looked at deploying
an app by showcasing the cloudbuilt
integration with cloud sauce
repositories however as a developer many
a times we also faced challenges where
we have to debug an app especially in
production and we're not able to
replicate those issues on a local
environment and that's where cloud sauce
depositories integration with
stackdriver really comes in handy there
are essentially two ways which we allow
you to debug your app in production the
first and the foremost way is strike
diverse debug snapshots this comes in
really handy when you're actually
debugging an app in production let's
take the following example as an
instance you're trying to debug an app
in production but that issue is being
faced only by one specific user and as a
result of which identifying that issue
on your local environment becomes really
difficult and this is where start Devi's
debug snapshot provides you details it
captures the entire call stacks it
inspects the local variables in fact to
do this you do not even have to slow
down or stop your app and the best part
is once you select the lines on which
you have to set up these debug snapshots
all your running instances of the app
can start automatically capturing these
debug snapshots the other way of
debugging with stack de Ville is lock
points as Nicole said stackdriver
debugger also lets you set debug log
points debug log points allow you to set
a custom log message on a particular
line of code that custom log message can
then reference the current application
state as well as only log under certain
conditions for example you may want to
log the
value of a variable only if the value of
that variable is outside of an expected
range I like to think of it kind of like
printf debugging except you don't need a
single printf in your code and since
you're using stackdriver debugger in
production it's important that you don't
even need to restart or stop your
application finally stackdriver debugger
also integrates with SAC driver logging
which means that you can store search
analyze and alert on these debug events
let's go ahead and take a look at debug
snapshots and debug log points in a demo
again can we switch over to the demo
please
here we can see the stackdriver debugger
a user interface at the top we have a
service selector this allows us to
choose between the various services and
versions of those services that we have
deployed I'm going to go ahead and
switch over to the one that we've now
promoted to 100% and is backed by the
cloud source repository at the commit we
just made stackdriver debugger
automatically pulls in that source code
and allows me to navigate through the
entire file tree we're looking at
guestbook Pi now which is where the bulk
of the logic for this application exists
now when a user goes in and posts a
message the application that happens
within this function down here called
post now I'm sure you've all been in
situations where you've had a user
running up against your production
service they're running into a problem
you try repoing it locally it doesn't
repro you try repoing it on your
production service as well and you just
can't repro it stackdriver debugger can
come in to help a lot with those types
of situations here I can go ahead and go
into my snapshot panel and set a
condition saying user email equals cloud
source repositories 2019 which is the
name of the email I'm currently logged
in with at gmail.com and let's go ahead
and set this snapshot on the greeting
dot foot which is where we're gonna
insert the greeting someone signs in a
guestbook into our data store and now we
have a snapshot waiting there you know
it may be in the next five minutes could
be in the next day but when a user comes
in with that email address it's gonna
capture the exact application state that
that user was looking at so we can find
out what was happening for them we can
also set debug log points and so in the
meantime while we're waiting for that
user I kind of want to see what's
happening for other users so I can go in
and click on that same line and for now
I'm just gonna say if true so I'm always
going to have this debug log point
happen
every time someone posts a message and
I'm just gonna say email and log the
user email I can then choose to add that
debug log point as informational as a
warning or as an error and as I said
earlier all of that integrates back with
all of your other logs and stack driver
logging so I'm going to add that log
point and now we just wait for something
to happen so let's go over to the
application and make something happen so
I'm gonna sign the guestbook again
saying thank you all for coming to our
talk and the guestbook is signed and we
can return to cloud debugger
here we can return to the snapshot and
we can see that the snapshot was
captured this user posted in the default
guestbook and that looks right that's
one I currently have selected and it
matched the user email that I was
specifically looking for I can then dig
into the other local variables such as
inside greeting I can see the value of
the message that was written such as
thank you all for coming to the talk as
well as seeing the entire call sack of
the application at that point to see if
maybe something was executed that I
didn't expect to be executed I can also
go in and look at our logs and by
refreshing the logs I can see that
indeed this log Point was hit and we now
have a log in our logging system saying
this user visited and we get that if any
other user visited as well so I hope you
all enjoyed seeing stackdriver debugger
it's actually one of my favorite tools
we have on GTV and I highly suggest you
give it a try I'm gonna hand it back to
him to kill now to wrap things up and
explain the main takeaways from our talk
times you simply switch back to the
slides so today we saw three specific
things we spoke about developing in
applications using cloud sauce
repositories during that stage we
specifically saw mirroring source code
from github and bitbucket to cloud sauce
repositories we spoke about how get lab
integration is coming soon as a part of
that process we also spoke about code
search and how code search lets you
search across all the repositories you
have access to we showcased push block
functionality which ensures that
security keys are not stored within
source control management systems that
completed the first part during the
second piece we specifically spoke about
cloud sports
repositories integration with cloud
build which lets you automate your build
test and deployment process of your
pipeline in case you are working with
containers we spoke about how you can
leverage continue registry vulnerability
scanning
along with binary authorization to set
up specific policies and finally in the
third part of the presentation we spoke
about how you can use strike driver to
debug applications in production with
that thank you so much for coming
we are still over here for any questions
and we would really appreciate if you
could provide your feedback in the next
stop we hope to see you again thanks a
lot
[Applause]
[Music]